in 2002 I had the great honor of sharing
the Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine with Sydney Brenner and john
sulston this prize was awarded in honor
of our studies of the nematode
Caenorhabditis elegans and for me the
major recognition was for studies that
my laboratory had done concerning the
phenomenon of programmed cell death also
known as Apatow psious in short we were
studying the basic developmental biology
of this nematode this round worm C
elegans and by doing so we found
mechanisms for programmed cell death for
Apatow sious that proved to be conserved
amongst animals including human beings
and elucidated mechanisms that are now
being used for targets in pursuits of
treatments for human diseases as diverse
as neurodegenerative diseases autoimmune
disorders and cancer
now I'm sometimes asked when I knew that
our studies of this worm would prove
relevant to human biology and human
disease and in a sense I think that from
the beginning I thought this would
probably be the case um despite the fact
and and I should say this emphatically
despite the fact that some peers and
also some NIH study sections don't think
much about studies of any organisms that
are not mammals my bias and the culture
which I had grown up was that an
understanding of basic biology in any
organism was likely to reveal features
that would prove to be widespread maybe
even universal and that the biological
principles that emerged would be
informative in a very very broad way and
the reason I believe that really goes
back to my own training I did my PhD
studies on the bacteriophage t4 now
going back some years before that uh in
the early days of phage studies there
were individuals like Luria and
dallbrooke who were interested in
studying the genetics of phage and they
were criticized some people said phage
they're not even going to have genes and
those who accepted the fact that they
might have gene said well even if they
have genes those genes are not going to
be relevant they're going to have
nothing whatsoever to do with the genes
we care about genes in human beings now
of course everybody in biology today
knows or perhaps I should say should
know that the history proved these
critics wrong it was studies of
bacterial viruses that led to the
elucidation of the basic mechanisms of
heredity that led to the definition and
understanding of the genetic code and
led to the revolution in genetic
engineering that so characterizes both
biological research and the
pharmaceutical industry's efforts today
so I had the sense from this phage
background that our studies of C elegans
would prove to be general but I couldn't
know that so the question then is when
did I know when did I have the
the aha moment that said okay what we're
doing is going to be relevant in the
answer to that's easy
the answer is February 12 1992 this was
the day that I got a fax from a graduate
student in my lab Michael Han Gartner I
was at a scientific conference and
Michael had been studying one of the
genes that we had characterized in our
in our analyses of C elegans program
cell death a gene called said nine CED
four cell death abnormal gene number
nine and said nine was a key gene in the
regulation of programmed cell death and
C elegans and what Michael was trying to
do was to characterize this gene not
just through formal genetic analysis but
also through molecular analysis and the
first step in this process was to
identify a molecular clone of said 9 and
look and see did it remind us of any
other gene that was known what Michaels
facts told me was that when he had
searched the literature and this was
very early days of gene sequencing of
this sort when he had searched the
literature I'm sorry the database and
looked to see if there are any similar
genes out there one emerged at the top
of the list far above anything else and
this match was a human gene
it was a human cancer gene a
proto-oncogene known as bcl-2 now said
nine had been shown to protect cells in
C elegans from programmed cell death our
studies
bcl-2 from work of cancer biologists had
been shown to protect cells against
programmed cell death and to cause
cancer because it was protecting cells
for
I'm dying that normally should die so
cells that should die instead lived that
led to their survival and consequently
led to cancerous growth so this finding
that a worm gene that protects against
program cell death during C elegans
development and a human gene that
protects against programmed cell death
and when Miss expressed basically would
protect cells that should die from doing
so thereby leading to cancer
this finding said that these two genes
that function similarly look similar in
their sequence and this was the finding
that said to me that if these two genes
are so similar in both function and
structure there must be a pathway of
genes that is similar between organisms
as diverse as this microscopic roundworm
and us this was a moment of excitement I
was absolutely thrilled because what it
said was that the studies we had been
doing in terms of analysis of C elegans
were going to be relevant to an
understanding of human biology and human
disease I should add that it was this
finding that made the biomedical
community pay attention prior to this I
was basically doing abstract genetic
studies of an organism most people were
paying no attention to involving a
phenomenon that most people were paying
no attention to suddenly we were working
on a gene and a pathway that was key in
human disease our work was no longer
abstractions from genetics
but suddenly had a strong foothold in
the future of human biology and I would
say the rest is history at least for me
thank you
you